let's introduce two people that you may
be familiar with if you've been uh
watching the show over the last month or
so two women who certainly know their
way around Westminster former political
advisor to labor Isha hazarika and
samashar who was a special advisor to
the conservative Home Secretary David
lovely to have you on uh both of you
um I want to talk if I may about Dominic
roll to start um it feels like everyone
is thrown in their two cents on this and
the reaction to the port almost splits
down culture War lines but from two
people who really know what it's like to
be working in government in the Civil
Service as well I'm interested in that
relationship between ministers and the
civil service has it broken down is
there a problem and what's just what's
your view
so I think the relationship between
ministers and civil servants is actually
quite dysfunctional generally and so and
you're right there is this kind of like
cultural split about who's on you know
Dominic Robb's side and he's on the
Civil Service side and that is not the
right conversation to have in my view
there's a couple of steps back from this
which is have we ended up in a situation
where people don't feel that they're
able to either direct their civil
servants to do what they're supposed to
do be held accountable by Parliament and
by the electorates and how are civil
servants in a position where they don't
feel that they can talk back and there's
it was a really interesting article in
the Sun from an Insider anonymously
written about the state of the ministry
of justice and there was something that
really struck me which was there are
failings in our system that we are not
addressing and instead of doing things
like that we're actually talking about
what is essentially you know a
difficulty at the top rather than the
real policy guts of what needs to be
done in order to fix our prison system
for example so I think we all need to
take a bit of a step back and reflect on
really where is this dysfunction and how
are we going to fix it
it's slightly different I mean I started
life off as a Whitehall civil servant
and then I became a political advisor so
I've kind of been on both sides here and
I think for me it's a sign of a of a
really mediocre failing minister to be
at war with your civil service now the
Civil Service most civil servants want
to have a good relationship with their
minister they like that proximity to
power they want to be part of a team
which is exciting Dynamic delivering big
results so I think this kind of argument
that somehow like all civil servants are
you know this weird term The Blob rude
and also a bit rude and also that
they're kind of activists you know it's
I think that does the Civil Service you
know a great disservice if you like and
I think if you're a smart Minister and
if you're a good special advisor I'm
sure you are a good special advisor when
you're in the home office you you
realize that having a good team which
involves your civil servants is
absolutely Paramount to delivering stuff
and I think for all this Bluster we hear
from Dominic Robb that he was some Titan
of modern politics and he's going to be
this huge loss to public life what did
he actually achieve you know he wasn't
around when the Afghanistan evacuation
happened he was famously still on
holiday said that the sea was closed and
he presided over a disaster at Justice
you've said yourself the justice system
is is absolutely
um crumbling there's so many things that
went wrong so I think this sort of
culture war of just you know having this
massive fight and blaming the civil
service for everything is really really
dangerous
the the difficulty is is that the system
is not set up well right if you were to
if you were to go back a minister goes
into a department and they don't really
know anybody there the brief they are
learning as they go on the job and they
don't have the power to hire or fire
anybody that's there so they they are
literally being dropped into this system
without any sort of understanding of how
it works I mean that's like a flawed way
of kind of managing it I I totally take
your point that actually you do need to
help people learn how to be better
managers
um and in departments that they are not
used to and that they don't know their
way around and that there is something
on the other side of it as well because
even civil servants will say that the
system isn't working as well as it
should that has got lots of multifaceted
one of them being that they had two huge
shocks to the system one being brexit
and the second being the pandemic and
there needs to be some kind of
reappraisal not in the kind of Dominic
Cummings language of kind of like
blowing it all up but certainly even
within the Civil Service you will hear a
lot of gripes about how things could
work work better is there is there a
resistance in the Civil Service towards
specifically conservative policies
because it feels like this is the kind
of accusation from dominant ra that
people just didn't agree with what he
was doing and that's why he met
resistance well I think there's
sometimes there is a frustration or when
you're on the political side of things
and I saw this being a special advisor
where you know your minister wants the
department to deliver really quickly and
there's an issue about the the scale of
of the real estate and the reality and
also you know your Minister's political
career is hanging in the balance because
people like you and us will be you know
dissecting it on the airwave so they
want things to be delivered but the
civil service is there to also make sure
that ministers act within the parameters
of the law and also to make sure that
things are realistic that they're cost
effective and that they are within like
certain kind of rules I mean that's one
of the the great functions of British
democracy having this sort of civil
service that is there yes to kind of Aid
and help Ministers of all political use
depending on who the government is but
but to make sure that you are acting
within parameters and I just come back
to this point like the best ministers
and the best secretaries of State yes I
do take your point they go into new
departments they don't know people but
they know how to build teams for example
you know you know I was an opponent of
George Osborne you know when I was
working for for Ed miliban but certainly
people I knew the treasury said that
actually he treated people really well
that the treasury people had a lot of
time for for him and I think it's not so
much that
civil servants are desperately morally
against the things that have been done a
lot of the ass and we know this because
stuff has been challenged and the
Court's left right and Center you look
at austerity you look at how things have
been cut it's very hard for people to
deliver when the kind of Foundations
aren't there whether it's sort of money
and resources and and realistic
expectations I I've got to say I don't
think it's necessarily a conservative
issue because I've definitely spoken to
labor and lib done people who've had the
same frustrations and the same problems
that Dominic Robb has spoken about it's
interesting
um I we're entering a local election
territory right uh where the campaigning
is ramping up we're in the campaign
period and I'm entering that slightly
frustrating period with politicians
where everyone was very very on brand
and on message and there's a lot of
expectation management going on right so
I'm getting a straight answer is hard
ahead of the local elections what are
the conservatives firstly going to be
hoping for them I'll talk to you after
so I think they're going to hope for a
sort of muted
um losses uh I don't think there's any
sense that they're gonna they think that
there's going to be kind of like a
massive Victory there so you're right
the expectation management has
absolutely begun
um I think that if they are able to hold
on to enough they can say that actually
this is just par for the course a
government that's been in a long time
and in the natural sort of um way of
things that this is what the results
have been I mean there was talk about at
one point about if it was a disastrous
result then Boris Johnson could be
waiting in the wings waiting to take
over has that now disappeared to see my
sense from people I'm speaking to is
that it's not really going to be the
moment that they all decide that
something's going to change now there
might be some kind of a plan of action
with Boris Loyalists and and Boris
people but whether there is enough of an
audience who wants to listen to that I
think that's been quite diminished I
think people just wanted a period of
calm so that they can actually build
build up to go towards the general
election and Aisha and I were discussing
this earlier you know it is a big
electoral test for both Rishi sunak and
Kia stamba so I suppose I suppose the
stakes are quite High yeah Stakes high
for stamina as well right it is
interesting because this is like you
know it's going to be a sort of key test
probably the first the last set of
Elections possibly before we have the
next general election so this is really
important pitch ruling and the narrative
that both sides will be scrambling to
establish you know after the results are
really really important I mean the
conservatives are doing the classic and
management you know they're like we're
going to lose a billion seats
you know it's like it's kind of like
more seats than there are yes exactly
like every seat in the country we're
going to lose so there's that kind of
thing but what's going to be interesting
is is for is for Libra I think Libra
again I think muted is a good word I
think labor will be hoping that they'll
be kind of briefing sort of muted
expectations I think they'll be
definitely hoping to to win seeds I
think the the difficulty for labor is
going to be you know how big is that
number going to be and if it's not past
a certain threshold I mean what's also
going to be interesting is and we don't
talk about these it's going to be
interesting to see how the liberal
Democrats do and the greens do because
often in these local elections you know
there's lots of people particularly in
that blue wall area where I think a lot
of people could go liberal Democrat or
green so I think they're going to be
really interesting as well and I guess
the s p may be quite relieved that there
aren't any in Scotland right and the SNP
is having another um Torrid week you
know we saw the the treasurer Colin
Beatty have to stand aside you know
there was a big moment for Hamza Yusuf
to try and reset things but of course
the whole thing is dominated by yet more
arrests I mean it's not good when you're
the first Minister and you have to say
yes I was surprised when one of my
colleagues was
we are not a criminal operation you know
it's so I think you know he's he's
trying to do these resets and then
there's this the Specter of more arrests
hanging over and of course now there are
rumors swirling around that there will
be you know potentially even Nicholas
sturgeon might be called in for
questioning as well so there's there's
still that huge moment of anxiety for
the msmp we learn as well that the party
still owes Peter Murrell money um as
well so it is a really tough time and of
course there was a an opinion poll this
week which shows that support for the s
p has dropped to the lowest level since
2014. so all of this Scandal is really
doing a lot of damage to this very new
first Minister and it feels like the
kind of sins of the the fathers and the
mothers that went before him are hanging
over him now difficult start isn't it
for the new leader incredibly difficult
and actually I don't see how he comes
back from this because there is as you
say there was an attempted to relaunch
it sort of putting out his vision uh for
his leadership but it's seems to be
completely ignored and how does one
actually navigate when there's always
going to be these stories and this thing
hanging over him I I don't think it's
possible for him to have a successful
run at this